[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui s'est passé dans le monde que la
normalité passe maintenant pour l'excellence quand avons-
nous abaissé nos normes nous vivons dans
un environnement où les gens sont aveugles
ce que vous ne voyez pas vous ne savez pas
hors de vue hors de  l'esprit
[Musique]
quelque chose s'est passé aujourd'hui quelque chose de mauvais
un mari ne revient pas
Rana
il y a beaucoup d'argent
et maintenant les gens le veulent de nous
maintenant la meilleure chose que nous ayons à faire
est d'être qui nous sommes pourquoi parce que personne ne
pense que nous  J'ai les couilles pour réussir
mais tout ça tourne mal Je veux que
mes enfants sachent que je ne me suis pas contenté de rester assis
là et de le prendre
J'ai fait quelque chose dans cette ville récolter ce que
vous semez
espérons-le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[  Musique]
toi